hi I'm RJ Mitte
and for this Father's Day we are paying
tribute to fictional fathers who we all
know and love today I would like to pay
tribute to a great man some called him
Walter others called him Heisenberg but
I called him dad a lot of fathers say
they would do anything to provide for
their family but you Walter white really
meant anything be it cook meth poison a
child or choke a man named Crazy eight
with a bike lock you always made sure
that your family had an a.1 day you
sacrificed so much to make sure your
family always had what was most
important breakfast everything you did
was for your children and also your
pride and a ton of money but definitely
for your children to which someone else
had been jealous of all the time you
spent with Jesse Pinkman a little but
you never let my girlfriend choked on
her own vomit so we all know you really
loved most
I do wish we could have spent more time
together though a kid can only play with
his uncle Hanks minerals for so long
instead of spending your dying days with
your wife and children you chose to
spend them spraying a white supremacist
drug syndicate with an automatic machine
gun which was an awesome I mean what
other dad could rig an old Mexican
cartel leaders wheelchair with a bomb
that blows up a chicken franchise owning
drug dealers ripping his entire face off
my TV dad Walter White most dads tell
lame knock-knock jokes but you you were
the one who knocks and for that we all
thank you and wish you a Happy Father's
Day this Father's Day we are saying
thanks to film and TV dads who touched
our lives being a 12 year old boy can be
a confusing time especially when your
father dresses an old ladies clothes